hey there y'all kept a girl waiting now
which one's the prince
aha hello your highness
Congrats on your wedding not hitch just
yet lady luna phrase groom to be here in
hammerhead apologies for taking so long
you bet save your apologies for papa
well that makes you sandy Sid's
greasemonkey granddaughter we should all
get a picture with her
hmm Umbra bringing us stuff no boy but
dog can really track a scent I'm afraid
you're out of luck
are we the boots bring you here what
about well they'll not take you for
what's your story I'm an impatient
traveler ready to turn ship the cease
fire is getting us nowhere
what's this some sort of souvenir they
make those no consider it your allowance
huh yeah then who's allowing us a man of
no consequence what's that look for
it's in all the papers
what is insomnia boss what this your
idea of a joke I need you to calm down
so I can explain I was calm as I'm gonna
get there was an attack the Imperial
Army has taken the crown city as treaty
room tempers flared blast lit the night
sky when the smoke about the Citadel had
cleared the King was found dead no wait
hold on we had no way of knowing what
knowing what that the signing was last
night that until the wedding oh yeah I
know that was the plan yet the reports
of the invasion are all the same how
could every headline in the kingdom be
wrong
hmm
if only what else do we know huh well
then we can't be sure until we see it
with our own eyes and that means we go
back to insomnia might not be safe for
us there I might not be safe for us here
turn back
yeah keep it on oh don't bother
hello